à l'auditorium du conservatoire de mâcon
le public s'installe
vu qu'on s'apprête à assister à un
concert de musique classique on se dit
que la moyenne d'âge de l'assistance est
plutôt insolite
l'explication nous est donnée par une
musicienne du concert impromptu qui a
créé cet événement
c'est vraiment un festival de musique
classique et contemporaine dédié aux
enfants parce qu en général quand on dit
festival c'est pour les grands personnes
en cet équipement qui est vraiment cette
proposition sur le marché de la musique
classique
tout d'abord yves charpentier le
fondateur du concert impromptu nous le
contact avec son jeune public
puis le concert débute avec une
transcription pour quintette à vent d'un
mouvement de la symphonie fantastique de
berlioz
[Musique]
ici pas de partition le concert
impromptu a fait le choix de jouer
parker ceux qui l'interprètent comme ils
ne sont pas figées derrière des pupitres
les corps des musiciens bouger se
déplacent ce que fera remarquer un
enfant à l'issue du concert un autre est
ravis d'écouter du hautbois l'instrument
qu'il commence tout juste à apprendre et
qu'il trouve plutôt fastoche moi je
pense que le voit c'est pas très
difficile la seule chose qui est
difficile c'est arrivé à mon prendre les
touchant tant les clés est tout
simplement celle qui difficile mais
sinon après je trouve que c'est plutôt
pas simple mais pas trop compliqué
[Musique]
l'enfant il ne triche pas il est sincère
il a une joie spontanée et c'est vrai
que c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire avec
la musique d'avoir ce geste là 1er brut
primitif que l'enfant a confié le chante
quand thierry quand il sourit
il n'y a pas du tout de masques 30
concert pour ces petits vernis par une
douzaine de musiciens de haute volée
voilà vraiment de quoi donner envie de
retourner en enfance
[Applaudissements]